el presidente de brasil y jair bolsonaro
cambian 9 ministros a tan solo seis
meses de las elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas de octubre porque dichos
ministros pretender ser candidatos al
senado de la cámara de los diputados y
por la actual ley electoral no pueden
ocupar cargos en el ejecutivo en el
período previo entre los ministros que
salen destaca tarsicio de freitas de
infraestructura que pretende presentarse
como gobernador de san paolo también
sale la todopoderosa ministra de
agricultura 3 a christina la musa del
agronegocio que quiere ser senadora y
sale en la polémica ministra de familias
y derechos humanos la pastora evangélica
de amar es alves que protagonizó muchas
polémicas a lo largo de su mandato
además todo apunta a que los próximos
días saldrá también el actual ministro
de defensa- braga neto que va a
concurrir como vicepresidente en las
elecciones presidenciales al lado de
bolsonaro con eso el actual jefe del
ejército va a asumir
la cartera de defensa iba a ser el
tercer cambio la cúpula del ejército en
cuatro años de gobierno de bolsonaro
algo que no se produjo ni siquiera
durante la época de la dictadura militar